jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors on
sait qu'un plan de soutien a déjà été
lancé par le gouvernement est ce que ça
veut dire aujourd'hui qu'il faudra autre
chose mais pour l'instant l'état a fait
en sorte que l'économie française ne
s'effondre pas complètement pendant ce
confinement 51 jours les entreprises y
ont trouvé un à l'arrêt à l'art est
pratiquement complet bac commerce de
détail pas sauf d'alimentaire pas de
commerce extérieur bien sûr pas
transport par d'investissement pas de
consommation donc pas de chiffre
d'affaires le résultat c'est qu'on a
effectivement perdu à peu près 27 % en
termes d'activité l'activité a été
plombé de 27% au mois d'avril un peu
comme en mars et que en termes de
croissance bien la banque de france
redis ça représente pratiquement 6 % de
croissance et sur l'année de par sa
représentera 10% de croissance en moins
alors l'économie s'y retrouve et
anesthésiés c'est comme si on avait mis
au niveau en coma artificiel et pendant
son coma artificiel
l'état a apposé des perfusions elle a
fait des prêts garantis aux entreprises
la organiser le chômage partiel a fait
des aides indirectes direct auto
entrepreneurs aux petits artisans
et puis au total on arrive quand même à
plus de 100 milliards d'euros comme
l'état n'a pas perçu dans le même temps
ni les impôts ni les taxes et les
charges
eh bien on va creuser un déficit
budgétaire aux environs de 180 milliards
auxquels il faudra ajouter le déficit de
la sécurité sociale qui est considérable
le déficit de la ratp de la sncf
alors je crois qu'on peut critiquer le
gouvernement sur beaucoup d'aspects de
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire sur les
masques sur les tests on peut on peut le
faire mais on ne pourra pas sans doute
critiquer ce gouvernement qui a mis
autant d'argent pour que le système
économique et social ne s'effondre pas
complètement ne s'autodétruise pas et
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle il
fallait redémarrer et allait redémarrer
on voit combien c'est difficile parce
que ce risque de redémarrage risque de
faire est de réveiller un peu le bleu le
virus en quelque sorte avec cette
appréhension de loire deuxième vague
peut être arrivé en juin
alors là bon coup franc ça n'est pas
très optimiste selon elle il va falloir
investir dans certaines entreprises pour
éviter des faillites
oui parce que je vous le disais à
l'instant on assume
via cette anomie va se réveiller elle
est en train dé se réveiller et quand
vous sortez du coma bas vous sens en
vous sentez pas bien il va falloir
réapprendre à marcher
il va falloir s'adapter aux nouvelles
conditions de vie il va falloir
appliquer les normes sanitaires ça va
demander des investissements tous à
regarder ce qui va se passer dans les
transports ou la restauration
pour respecter les gestes barrières on a
du mal aujourd'hui 1
il faut espaces et les clients ça veut
dire que la recette bas quasiment édifie
4 2 et tout ça va être de
l'investissement pour cela l'entreprise
n'a pas forcément les capitaux pour cela
pas de fonds 3 il va falloir lui
apporter ces fonds propres l'état a déjà
apporté de l'argent frais arnaud à air
france il faudra qu'il en apporte à la
sncf à la ratp est sans doute à beaucoup
d'autres entreprises pour qu elles pour
qu'elles évitent l'effondrement et
notamment le chômage de masse alors ce
sont des investissements dont on peut
qu'on peut financer plus facilement que
les dépenses de soutien un préalable
on sait exactement comment faire on a
vécu ce cas de figure
au moment de la crise et sa part émis en
2008 premier temps au maintien
d'entreprises en vie deuxième temps on
va essayer de la russe khl et jean marc
sylvestre
selon vous cette convalescence va-t-elle
durer longtemps vous savez on est quand
même dans l'union européenne
le pays qui va se retrouver très en
retard notamment par rapport à notre
principal partenaire
les allemands les allemands une
résilience beaucoup plus forte que la
nôtre
sa chute d'activité est beaucoup plus
faible elle s'est mieux défendu
l'allemagne a une capacité de résistance
beaucoup plus fort je vous le disais les
structures industrielles sont plus
solides
elle a plus de marge nous nous sommes
plus fragiles nous sommes plus
vulnérables ma dialogue social plus
compliqué on va dépendre de l'évolution
de l'épidémie évidemment donc dû
déconfinement il faut être là encore
très prudent et on voit bien tout le
monde essaie de faire cet effort parce
que si le pays se relâche on risque la
fameuse deuxième vague du mode juin et
là on sera obligé de reconfirmé et ça
risque d'être catastrophique les
allemands eux mêmes font très attention
le canada par exemple également vient de
prolonger son confinement singapour
qu'important été un modèle confine
jusqu'en juin si on est prudent si on
les civic si on est responsable ça doit
passer
ça doit nous permettre d'attendre de
revenir à des conditions normales
attendre quoi attendre évidemment un
vaccin parce que le vaccin c'est la
seule chose qui peut restaurer la
confiance mais ce vaccin il faut pas
l'attendre avant l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
éditorialiste économique d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce matin